and I've talked to men about this like  my friend's husband who's who's I think  they would deem him as like a high value  guy like he's got the five whatever  things they look for right and he said I  there's some fat like fat or bigger  girls that I'm attracted to but I  wouldn't date them because typically  they're very undisciplined interesting  and because you know if if she's big in  one area that means she's probably not  good with her finances they typically  have debt and it doesn't and it doesn't  mean it doesn't it doesn't mean every  single one right it doesn't mean but  it's just in general like typically the  guys that go to the get up early and go  to the gym they have good jobs because  they're very disciplined and bums don't  tend to be in the best shape